tu aimes bien tenir la barre comme ça
c'est excitant c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
man
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hashtagbar on va désigner le meilleur
danseur à la barre ce soir vous allez
tous ensemble vous avez tous dansé
finalement Daniel c'est bon tu as fait
c'est bon
attention
j'appelle Gilles Verdez
[Applaudissements]
vas-y vas-y
attention
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant pour l'instant pour
l'instant pour moi c'est le mieux
de la corde à nœud là
[Rires]
ça dépend de la musique mettez une bonne
musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais non ça commence bien mais j'ai tapé
une boule
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je reviens de maladie j'ai retrouvé ma
petite cataracte
[Applaudissements]
pour moi c'est le meilleur la première
fois ce qui prend du plaisir
[Rires]
faites-vous plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Valérie c'est pas c'est pas nul c'est
pas nul c'est pas nul du tout
les chéris nous restent dedans
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal
arrête avec cette torche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quelle musique souhaites-tu quelles sont
la musique est-ce que tu veux David
pour danser d'accord
[Applaudissements]
la meuf a travaillé au sunshine
un peu lente je crois que c'est ce
qu'elle veut regarder parce que nous
nous avez pas avancé
[Applaudissements]
de mettre ça on dirait qu'on va manger
un yaourt
[Rires]
bordel de merde [ __ ]
trouvé un genre à la [ __ ] moi j'ai le
temps la musique de Raymond était pas
mal
[Musique]
[Rires]
pas tout de suite on répète déjà à côté
de la barre c'est spectacle
je ne rigole pas la barre va hyper bien
prendre le bus non mais je te jure ça
devrait hyper bien là-bas merci les
Chéries on va on va trouver une musique
quand parce qu'il est déçu j'ai Clara
Morgane qui m'attend j'ai un gars de la
CGT qui arrive tout à l'heure alors on
va régler pas mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
mon avis ça c'est une image que je vais
vendre
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes senti
mal à un moment vous êtes assises
c'était un peu court
c'est ce que m'a dit ton ex
[Applaudissements]